Molti di voi ultimamente mi fermano per strada, dicendomi:
"So che ti da fastidio, però bla bla bla bla".
No, non è vero. Sfatiamo questo mito.
Non è vero che mi dà fastidio se mi fermate per strada.
Dipende dalla situazione.
Dipende dal contesto socio-politico della giornata.
Se io ho fatto la spesa e mi vedete
con le buste del Crai in mano;
ma in giro non c'è nessuno, e sono da solo,
mi potete tranquillamente fermare.
E' in altri casi in cui si pone il problema del rompimento di coglioni.
Per esempio, che ne so, quando sono
al ristorante giapponese con i miei amici.
Siamo lì che parliamo di cazzate, com'è andata
la giornata, cosa stai facendo in questo periodo...
Finiamo di mangiare, ci alziamo
tutti quanti e andiamo a pagare.
Poco prima di andare alla cassa, mi fermano due ragazzi,
nel tavolo più lontano, nell'angolo più remoto del ristorante.
Che tra l'altro dire "ragazzi" è molto generoso,
perché avranno avuto...
...40 anni, probabilmente, credo?
E dopo la prima domanda, avevo già capito
che sarebbe andata a puttane la serata.
Perché quella domanda è stata:
"Tu sei quello che fa video su youtube, giusto?"
Eh ohibò, siamo finiti all'inferno.
Questi ragazzi erano due, e io ho notato che
mentre uno mi faceva delle domande,
l'altro si nascondeva quasi con la mano,
guardando il piatto di ravioli al vapore
che stava mangiando, ignorandolo bellamente.
E io comunque mi fermo e, con un sorriso imbarazzato, gli rispondo: "Sì".
E lui continua dicendomi: "Quindi tu sei quello
che fa recensioni di videogiochi?!".
E io lì stavo morendo! Che imbarazzo!
Cosa ti rispondo?! Non lo so!
No, non sono-! Cioè sì, più o meno. Nel senso che ho un canal--, però non è che faccio recens-- cioè, cos'è,
m-- ma che va che domande...?! Ma scusami...?!
Io mi stavo spezzando le gengive, da quanti denti
stavo stringendo da quel momento di imbarazzo,
e quindi me la sono voluta giocare veloce dicendogli: "Eh, più o meno".
E allora lui mi fa la domanda fatidica! Mi guarda
e mi dice: "Ma scusa, tu non sei... Yoshim...
Yoshim...?" E Yoshim! E Yoshim tua sorella!
Ma cosa vuol dire?! Cioè, perché mi hai fermato se non sai chi sono?
E il suo amico, che guardava i ravioli, gli dice, senza alzare lo sguardo,
dice: "No, Yotobi". Yotobi. Eh, Yotobi! Yoshim,
è la stessa cosa! Ma allora, scusa,
tu perché mi hai fermato, se non sai chi sono?
Perché io sono in questo momento?
Come è successo che diventare famosi su Youtube,
mi avrebbe fatto ritrovare in un ristorante giapponese
a dire: "No, non sono Yoshim", e non sapere cosa fare?
Ma cosa vuol dire, come son finito...?
Quale congiunzione astrale mi ha portato
ad essere in questo momento qui?
E io avevo capito tutto! Avevo capito
che era l'altro che mi aveva riconosciuto
e l'ha detto al suo amico, che non sapeva chi fossi, e allora, per fare lo scherzone "best friend",
mi ha fermato, dicendomi: "Tu sei quello che fa
le recensioni di videogiochi". Ma allora?!
Quindi, se proprio dovete fermarmi, fate come hanno fatto con John Lennon! Mi fermate e mi dite:
"Ciao, sei John Lennon?"
"Sì" *pphhuuf*
E mi sparate un colpo nel petto e finisce lì,
almeno mi risparmio l'imbarazzo.
Porca troia!